der sport report ist das neueste produkt
des österreichischen bundesheeres wir
schaffen es damit die leistungen unserer
450 jahre sportlerinnen und sportler ins
richtige licht zu rücken
und wenn wir über den sport rapport
treten dann würde er niemals so
stattfinden auch diese art und weise
ohne einen ganz besonderen moderator
unser andreas und er der ein perfekter
sportler ist und im schwimmbereich
seinesgleichen sucht aber auch ein
moderator ist der das perfekt macht und
freuen sie sich ja vieles das sie
erwartet wir haben auch die sportlerin
des jahres mit kabarett artig bei uns
zukünftig werden wir zwei mal im monat
eine folge starten und freuen sie sich
mit der ersten davon wir zeigen unsere
sägewerken diese in ein richtiges licht
und bringen sie umzugs für rasant und
freuen sie sich darauf
[Musik]